you and Muslims that rape little
[Music]
kids we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of Allah subhana
tala in the country of Norway
click on the link and donate now for the
sake of Allah
subh brothers and sisters and dear
friends Garcia somebody who fought
another Muslim and Subhan Allah actually
accuse that Muslim of not being a real
Muslim because that Muslim fighter
missed the whole of Ramadan so we can
prepare for this
fight like imagine your this one thing
garia said which is true you're
preparing for a fight you're doing
something Allah has told you not to do
yes to to to fast and you don't fast
because win a fight and you lose a fight
as well you lost a fight against this
opponent this Garcia fool and then you
lost your opponent against Shayan knock
out both ways so success comes from
Allah even if you fasted Allah given you
Victory and if Allah has written that
you're going to lose you've just lost
fasting all those rewards for what for a
fight that you lost already anyway so
gazia said called him out for that and
he spoke the truth that matter TR the
truth that you can't say he's not a
Muslim but he was yeah he was saying oh
you're not a true Muslim you can't
really say that but anyways the point is
this garia then came and said he placed
£20 million for the Palestinians now all
of a sudden this recording that came out
of him which you can hear for yourself
in a minute brother and sisters [__] you
and Muslims rape little kids bro all you
[__] bro you guys are weird as all
you Muslim ass [__] weird ass
[__] you're going to regret saying
all this when you gu what guess what I
will never be touched cuz I'm with God
I'm with Jesus oh my god you're an idiot
right Nico regrets what he says and
think Ryan gonna regret what he said I
won't I I'm not regretting it I swear to
God I'm not I've never so that video
audio you can see is him insulting the
Muslims F Muslims I don't know what
happened you see what happens is when
people do something if they don't do it
for the sake of Allah for the sake of
God I don't know if some Muslim upset
him if some Muslim said something to him
he start saying F all Muslims all the
same ET and then he starts to talk
about r a p of kids or something like
that and that he believes is like oh I
believe in Jesus I believe in God nobody
can touch what the f you talking about
man it's not even about someone touching
you or not you flipping clown the pro
the point is this that it shows that if
you genuinely did something for a group
of people and it was genuinely for their
for the sake of God this is why for
doing things for the sake of Allah is so
important you're not doing it with
anything in return you're not saying I'm
going to do a so no you're doing it
purely for the sake of God meaning even
if someone did something wrong to me
even if I lent someone some money he
came and started backbiting talking
against me that's fine I lend that money
for the sake of Allah you back biting is
irrelevant equation I will lend you
money again because I'm doing this for
the sake of God not because because I'm
doing this so you can speak good of me
this is why Islam is so unique when it
comes to the for the sake of Allah now
you've come out and you started to now
talk about kids and all that kind of
stuff my friend go to Google and write
pedophiles and the majority of them are
white middle-aged men most likely that
looks like you or Tommy Robinson yes
middle man okay they look like them
pedopile Rings Jimmy savil to Epstein
yes you guys are known for this man how
are you coming and throwing M us you
guys are the ones that are known for
flipping doing this for centuries for
decades Jim sa has been getting away
from it you guys are known for traveling
to Thailand and Africa and different
countries and abusing little kids so
don't come to with that crap not only
that it's in your Bible numbers CH 31:18
if I'm not mistaken where it says Go and
Kill men women children yes and any
woman that's not been touched by men
keep them for yourself little girls
Rabbi say this as young as 3 years old
this is the Jesus of the Old Testament
mate this is your God stipulating okay
this is prescriptive okay not just
describing it's describing you what to
do and even in 1st Samuel 15: 2 to3 go
go to amikit and kill men women children
baby and donkeys okay this is what
Israel is doing today to the
Palestinians your book is full of this
killing men women and children and
babies nowhere in the Quran does it tell
you to go and do this to little girls or
do that or kill nowhere so you clown
Garcia you absolute full crackhead you
smoking crack I don't want smoking yeah
you're absolute crackhead this is your
Bible that's saying this so before you
come and talk ill about Muslims okay you
are a piece of crap that's what you are
okay this is what drugs do to you guys
alcohol ex when somebody's drunk on
drugs or angry you see their true colors
and you can see very clearly if he
genuinely did what he did for the
Palestinians or dominating or even I
don't know if he did it or had a good
relation with the Muslims he would not
turn around this it shows either he had
that deep hatriot in his heart all along
or some Muslim abs and he took out on
all Muslims which shows how [__] he
is anyways that's all I'm going to say
brother and sisters Allah has told us in
the Quran do not take the Christians and
the Jews as intimate friends this is is
another example what Allah subh said is
H take it as H live by it brothers and
sisters okay do not take them as
intimate friends they can be friends but
not intimate friends our only intimate
friends and our allies and our brothers
and sisters is no one but the Believers
like Allah says in the
Quran in the Quran your son is not from
your family the Believers are and in the
B the Battle of bad same thing happened
there were people fighting their own
siblings mother father on the other side
Subhan Allah your Believers are the only
allies you have all I want to say was
garia you are a piece of
crap Islam net is raising funds to
establish a Masjid and Community Center
in Norway and they urgently need your
support every person who prays there
every kid that learns about Islam every
youngster that memorize the Quran all of
this and so much more can beat on your
scale of Good Deeds click the link and
donate what you can and share the video
for even extra reward